students in the clark county school
district have less than two weeks before
classes begin
last night ccsd announcing students and
staff
will be required to wear the mask
indoors in the classroom
kate houston live near rex bell
elementary to break down who this
applies to and if
more restrictions could possibly be put
in place kate
yes well students will want to pack a
few extra masks at the start of the year
this mandate will apply to both teachers
and students of all ages
one mom tells me that this could be a
challenge for young kids
i guess how do we make those masks into
our norms for
our younger ones cassandra bawaka is
preparing to send her three kids back to
class
while her two oldest are fine with masks
her soon-to-be third grader had a hard
time wearing it
i've got mixed feelings for it because i
know my son is going to have
he's going to have a problem and i don't
want it to become a disciplinary issue
so
my concern is going to be how how is
this teacher is going to handle that
students and staff must wear a mask
while indoors and on district buses
board of trustees president linda
cavazos says exceptions can be made for
those with medical or developmental
conditions
there is going to be a process that the
superintendent and his staff
will make available to all principals to
be able to answer the questions for
parents
and employees now bowaka is worried
these new mandates in rising cases
could lead to more restrictions the
ultimate thing i'm afraid of
is are we going to close the schools
because they've lost so much at this
time the board of trustees does not plan
to discuss
any more mandates at their next board
meeting in mid-august
our hope is is that the numbers will
turn around
but the vaccination rates will go up and
the covid numbers will go down
and we're looking forward to like a
reassessment with less than two weeks
before school baja is now trying to
prepare her kids to wear their mask
all day just like we have to you know
stop at a stop sign
or stop at a red light there's rules
that we do have to follow and it's for
the safety of everybody so i've been
stressing that to him
for the past 24 hours so we'll see how
that goes
well 95 percent of students have
registered for
in-person learning i did ask the
district if families who are concerned
about the rise in cases can switch
from in-person to distance learning they
said that those families
will need to reach out to the 13
designated schools who are doing
distance
learning and check of their space
reporting live kate houston 8 news now